hey just in case you don't know we have
a weekly anime podcast called rant cafe
that features me
knocks Taku all day anime and other
prominent anime youtubers and meemers a
new episode comes out every single week
and the podcast is available on iTunes
Spotify Google Play cast box I Heart
Radio and wherever you get your podcasts
it's also available on twitch and
youtube all the links are in the
description so please check us out what
is up everybody its Anna Mak here for
anime uproar and today I will be
discussing the most recent developments
in the seven deadly sins story including
the ongoing battle between demon King's
eldest and meliodas Elizabeth's new role
in that battle and the long-awaited
reveal of bond sacred treasure the holy
staff or sacred kajal curry juice we
have waited for over 300 chapters to see
the final sacred treasure in action and
now against the massive Lovecraftian
Endura that the demon king has summoned
from the demon world bond is finally
going to show us the true power of his
sacred treasure I can't wait to talk
about it all it's all fascinating stuff
so let's get into it if you enjoyed the
summon that Li sense content on this
channel you want to see more you can
leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to anime uproar don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell of course in this video we are
talking about the latest developments in
the seven deadly sins story so this
video will include manga spoilers please
proceed with caution you have been
warned as chapter 315 begins the
one-on-one battle between meliodas and
demon king zelgius continues from where
we left off in the previous chapter the
demon king yet again makes comments
about how disappointed he is that his
son meliodas turned out to be such a
failure man is it just me or is this guy
not the easiest dad to get along with
like Father's Day must be super awkward
anyway the demon king asked smelly Otis
what he plans to do now and whether he
is willing to destroy his own father and
his pathetic little brothers elders
meliodas responds that no he is going to
save zelgius and then he will disappear
from this world
and that should bring everything back to
normal and stop all the natural
disasters and other crazy stuff from
happening
well the oldest also threatens to kill
the demon king right here and now the
demon king gets mad when he hears this
but he also seems a bit shook to be
honest because he proceeds to grab
Elizabeth and he tries to use her as a
human shield against meliodas the demon
king says to my notice that he made a
big mistake by bringing dead weight like
Elizabeth to the battle because he now
plans to use her as a shield until he
gets his original power back however
Elizabeth proclaims that she didn't come
here to be a Sakura I mean to be dead
weight she came here to defeat the demon
king Elizabeth then proceeds to use arc
on the demon king followed by a bunch of
other goddess attacks including chase
and fury the demon king definitely isn't
having a fun time taking the brunt of
all these attacks and he calls Elizabeth
a little hussy ah the demon king classy
as always level 99 Waman respect her
meliodas then says that under estimating
Elizabeth is a mistake
because in the demon world she is known
as bloody Ellie now I like the fact that
elizabeth has developed so much as a
character and that naca bouzouki has
deliberately turned her into a strong
and useful character by the end of the
story she starts out as a young ditzy
teenager who is pretty useless overall
except for the occasions that she
accidentally heals people without even
realizing it because of her hidden
goddess powers nevertheless the more we
learn about Elizabeth the more we
realized that she was indeed a strong
independent and capable character in her
previous lives such as when she was Liz
in Danna for and especially in her
original life as the goddess Elizabeth
the more Elizabeth regains her memories
and the more we learn about her the more
she becomes a mature interesting and
strong character and I really do
appreciate this aspect of the story
Elizabeth is not just eye candy or comic
relief she has become a fully developed
character in her own right that said I
don't know how I feel about this whole
bloody Ellie business from what we've
seen in the past such as from flashbacks
to the previous holy war Elizabeth
seemed to oppose killing and she went
out of her way to defeat demons like
the Aryan man's beat without actually
killing them that hardly sounds like
someone who would have the nickname
bloody le in the demon world however it
is possible that further back in her
history before she met Mellie Otis and
realized the demons can be good she was
more ruthless kind of like Ludo shell or
like millio toes himself before he met
her I'm not sure how I feel about this
concept of bloody Ellie being a thing
but I'd like to ask you guys to tell me
what you think down in the comments why
do you think that elizabeth is
apparently known as bloody Ellie in the
demon world and what do you think of her
development as a character over the
course of the story the chapter then
shifts to the rest of the sins as they
prepare to face off against the massive
Lovecraftian indira that the demon king
has summoned from the demon world when
we first learned that the demon king was
summoning in dara from the demon world a
few people in the comments mentioned
that he better bring more than one in
dara because the Endura from the
prisoners of the sky movie wasn't that
impressive and so one in dara couldn't
possibly pose a challenge to the
powered-up sins but this particular
massive in dara is honestly straight out
of HP Lovecraft and it has the
horrifying ability to spew thousands of
indira spawn spawn that will quickly
spread all over Britannia unless they
are all destroyed as the sins struggled
to deal with the countless Endura spawn
merlin reveals that she has had bond
sacred treasure the holy staff curry
choose this entire time she hands it
over to bond saying that he should now
be able to draw the maximum potential
from it the chapter ends as bond takes
possession of his sacred treasure
meaning that in the next chapter we will
finally get to see the last sacred
treasure in action
we know King uses his sacred treasure
all the time Merlin go through and esken
or use there's pretty often and the
enemy Leodis use theirs once in a while
but now we will finally get to see bond
sacred treasure for the very first time
I am very excited to see what kind of
unique powers and abilities curry juice
will possess especially now that bond
has gotten so much stronger after
spending all that time in purgatory but
seriously what's the deal with Merlin
just collecting everyone's sacred
treasures and stashing them away I get
that she loves collecting interesting
magical
objects and creatures but you think that
she would have told bond that she had
his sacred treasure this whole time
Marilyn just likes being mysterious I
guess and then she likes being all
clutch in key moments my guess is that
perhaps Merlin was hanging on to the
sacred treasure because bond could not
bring out the treasures full potential
until he became much stronger and now he
is finally strong enough to do it
Merlin kind of implies this when she
says that after bonds latest powerup he
will be able to draw out the full
potential of the sacred treasure so it
is likely that bond needed to get
stronger before he could master the
power of kur choose whatever the reason
for Merlin keeping it I am so excited to
see the newly powered up bond using his
sacred treasure to its fullest potential
I can't tell you how much we've all been
wondering about curry juice and whether
bond will ever get to use it or if naka
bouzouki just forgot about it or
something so this is an extremely cool
turn of events the biggest question that
I am wondering about now is what kind of
special abilities bonds sacred treasure
is going to have is it just going to
increase the overall power of his
attacks or does it have a special
ability like meliodas ability to create
clones of himself using lost faith we
know that in purgatory bond learned to
counter the demon King's special ability
called the ruler by transferring his
power to the demon king which actually
damaged him as a result of the rulers
ability I wonder if this ability to
transfer some of his strength onto
others will come into play with his
sacred treasure as well well let me know
what you guys think do you think that
curry juice will just enhance bonds
existing power or will it let him use
some new special ability and if you
think that his sacred treasure does have
a special ability what do you think that
this ability will be let me know down in
the comments I always love hearing from
you if you enjoyed this video you can
leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to anime uproar don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell you can also follow us on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar for all
the latest seventh at least sends news
and updates also don't forget to check
out our brand new bond love the pain and
Eska Noir all hail Diwan shirts on anime
out Broadcom a huge thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons foursome
according our work I want to give a
special thank you to our pro hero to
your patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh chubs is the man and nothing
but a fan and another huge thank you to
our the one tier patrons the ones who
stand above all other clans including
baby ray ace
Ingrid ah a lowland Adam Maddy Mac and
Michael called that on if you guys feel
that our content provides value for you
and you want to support more be sure to
check out our patreon link in the
description even donating a single
dollar will give you access to our anime
uproar patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these amazing people as always
thank you guys so much for watching I
really appreciate it and until next time
see our space cowboys
[Music]